foi isso aí que eu vou falar sobre a
água o recurso essencial à vida
eu estou fazendo minha parte quando
quando fecha a torneira enquanto escova
os dentes quando toma um banho no máximo
de cinco minutos e quando lavo meu carro
meu quintal com água da chuva
eu sempre me identifiquei no meio
aquático como esporte como exposta como
esportes aquáticos praias e aquários
aqui vocês estão vendo a superfície
terrestre vista do espaço
vocês estão vendo que ela completamente
azul tem muitos poucos espaços de terra
a maior parte da superfície terrestre é
coberto por água água na superfície do
planeta 97% de água salgada 2% e de água
doce congelada e um por cento aquela
água que a gente precisa a água potável
mas eu tenho uma pergunta pra vocês que
estão na platéia
será que estamos cuidando da água
o pior inimigo da poluição é a água
então não joga embalagens de comida
palitos de picolé e latas de
refrigerante nós quando você vai à praia
o desmatamento das matas ciliares aqui
na imagem esquerda vocês estão vendo que
a área está toda desmatada está
acontecendo a degradação o que está
acontecendo ali também é a erosão aqui
na imagem o direito vocês estão vendo
que ela está muito mais preservada é
muito mais bonita
vamos imaginar assim os nossos filhos
são os nossos protetores dos olhos no
chão então a mesma coisa acontece com
matas ciliares
nascentes rios e lagos mas ainda existe
esperança
o que podemos fazer é não jogar o lixo
nas ruas e nos rios reciclar preservar
as peças e matas ciliares reflorestar
diminuir o desperdício e economizar
cuidar dos oceanos preservar ensinar às
crianças desde cedo educar para que
possamos garantir a vida no planeta a
água muito obrigado